تخلي الروس عن وطنهم ،
أدى أمر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بتجنيد رجال للقتال في حربه في
أوكرانيا إلى نزوح جماعي للمتهربين من
التجنيد الروس الذين يصطفون يوميًا هنا في
كازاخستان المجاورة للتسجيل
لدى السلطات المحلية ،
وتقول الحكومة الكازاخستانية إن أكثر من 200000
روسي  هربنا إلى هذا البلد في أقل
من أسبوعين أه نعم هربنا من
روسيا فاديم وهرب أليكسي من موسكو
الأسبوع الماضي هربًا من التجنيد
لا نريد هذه الحرب
ولا نعترف بموقفنا من
حكومتنا العديد من
أراضي روسيا  اختنقت الحدود لأسابيع مع
طوابير طويلة بينما يركض المواطنون للخروج من
مشروع المراوغين الذين يسافرون برا ينتظرون
أيامًا في الطابور أو يدفعون أموالًا كبيرة مقابل
تذاكر الطائرة النادرة
للهروب وهذه مجرد خطوة أولى كل يوم
يصل المزيد من الروس إلى محطة القطار هذه
في ألماتي مع  حقائب الظهر
الخاصة بهم ويخبرونك جميعًا بنفس الشيء
الذي كانوا يخشون إرساله
للقتال في أوكرانيا وتخلوا
عن بلدهم في  إشعار قصير
هذان الزوجان اللذان تركهما معًا ، هل
أتيت بسبب التعبئة
للحرب في أوكرانيا ، كانت هذه ركلة أخيرة
لبدء
رحلتنا ، أعتقد ، نعم ، هل
كنت تخشى أن
تقاتل في الحرب ، أليس كذلك؟  شيء
أريد أن أشارك فيه في طوفان
الوافدين الجدد يفاجئ أصحاب الأعمال المحليين
مثل مشغل مساحة العمل المشتركة
في وسط ألماتي
الذي سار فيه هذا الرجل النبيل للتو ، وهو أمر غير معتاد
أن نرى حياتهم المعتادة كل يوم مثل
هذا أنهم قادمون  مع حقائب ضخمة
لأنهم لم يتمكنوا من العثور على مكان
للعيش وهم يأتون إلى هنا
للعمل والجلوس وأنت تعرف أنك تبحث
عن بعض الذين تعرفهم عن أماكن إقامة ،
فهذه الوافدين الجدد من روسيا ،
نعم ، وصولهم إلى حقيبة الظهر على ظهورهم
في هذه المدينة  على بعد مئات الأميال من
الحدود الروسية ، تحدثت مع العشرات
من الروس الوافدين حديثًا بدءًا من
الأطباء إذا رفضنا الذهاب إلى هذه الحرب ،
يجب أن نذهب إلى السجن إلى أخصائيي الهندسة.
وطلاب الجامعة
هربتم من روسيا
هنا من التعبئة من أه من
الخدمة العسكرية نعم معظمهم لا
يريدون التعرف على هويتهم لحماية
أحبائهم الذين ما زالوا في روسيا كيف يمكنني المشاركة
في الحرب
دون الرغبة
في كسب هذه الحرب
هذا الرجل  يقول إن مسودة بوتين لم تترك له
خيارًا آخر سوى الفرار من البلاد
تاركًا زوجته وطفله وراءنا ، نحن
لا نثق في حكومتنا ، ولا
نؤمن بما يقولون إنه يقول إن
الحكومة الروسية شنت حملة على
المعارضة جعلت الاحتجاج عديم الجدوى
ترك المئات  الآلاف من الرجال الآن
يهربون فجأة في محاولة للعثور على عمل
وإقامة في دول أجنبية ،
أنا مواطن البلد الذي بدأ
جيدًا لم أؤيد هذه الحرب
أبدًا ،
لكن
بطريقة ما ما زلت على اتصال
بالدولة بسبب جواز سفري وأنا.  أنا
في نفس الوقت لاجئ
ومعتدي روسيون أون ذا ران يتشاركون
شعورًا جماعيًا باليأس
والذنب بسبب الدمار الذي سببته
حكومتهم
إيفان واتسون سي إن إن  الماتي كازاخستان